let me ask you something the fact that
I'm drinking
Lucroy fruit flavored sparkling water
and that I quite enjoy it does that
detract from my overall manliness and
the fact that I'm wearing a pink shirt
whilst drinking the Lacroix does that
affect one way or another and the fact
that I just used the word whilst instead
of wild how does that where does that is
that is that a help or hindrance in my
in my overall manliest you know what I
don't care anyway it's it's I'm it's I'm
not gonna be put in a box I'm not gonna
be labeled alright I'm not gonna say
gender is fluid for me but I don't have
to be gender solid either do I maybe I
could be more of a gender agender
pudding let us say you know that's these
are these are more enlightened times so
you guys need to need to catch up is all
I'm saying
alright um I
yes gender pudding is sounds like a
really really bizarre and weird flavor
of pudding so look I think that we're we
are headed to a dark place in our in
society right now in our country and it
seems that Democrats are trying very
hard to push us into that place and when
I say we're headed into that place and
we're being pushed there I should say
that we're headed or we're being pushed
further into that kind of dark place
because we were already in a you know
we're already there to a certain extent
we're already in a place where for
instance violent anarchist thugs can
shut down a city street and accost
anyone who happens to pass by which
which we've seen repeatedly over the
last few years and maybe you saw it
happen yet again over the weekend maybe
you didn't see because it's not the kind
of thing the media likes to report on
but the anti feh doug's shut down an
intersection in Portland over the
weekend and they blocked traffic they
physically threatened motorists to pass
by at one point they that was just
watching the video
where they chased down an elderly man
who was who was simply he was it looks
like he was just trying to drive through
he's just trying to get by and but they
were blocking the intersection trying to
direct traffic and saying no you you're
not allowed to come here and so this guy
just tried to get through and they
chased down his vehicle and they started
beating on his vehicle with batons while
screaming like right in his face
screaming obscenities at him and you
watched the footage of this happening in
Portland the police are nowhere to be
found
they're just having it's incredible but
in the more incredible thing is that
we're used to it that these people in
masks can just take over a street and if
you try to if you try to walk by they'll
just beat you up and nobody the police
are just letting it happen maybe because
they're told to let it happen whatever
the reason is they have the law
enforcement decided to give these these
domestic terrorists free reign for the
afternoon meanwhile while that was going
on you had the protesters and what
protesters I should say put that in
scare quotes in Washington DC who were
being arrested as they tried to disrupt
the Brett Kavanaugh hearings you had we
talked about a few days ago what was
disturbing but also pretty hilarious
scene of the protesters again in scare
quotes banging on the doors of the
Supreme Court clawing at the doors
screeching like zombies and it's just
and this all happened only a you know
only a few days several days after Ted
Cruz was chased out of a restaurant by a
swarming mob of of harasses in these
have become familiar scenes in America
and the thing is when we talk about the
Democratic response to all this it would
be too generous to say that well
Democrat politicians have been silent in
the face of all this no they haven't
been silent at all actually silence
would be an improvement over what we've
seen from a lot of these people they've
actually encouraged it remember what
Maxine Waters said infamously to her
supporters a couple months ago she said
whenever you see you know somebody in
the troubled ministration you see a
Republican create a crowd and tell them
they're not
welcome anywhere that was her direct
quote from her they're not welcome
anywhere is what she encouraged her
supporters to to say and to do senator
Hirono was was asked on CNN a couple
days ago whether she thinks it may be
going too far to run senators out of
restaurants and to go to their homes to
go to their homes okay that's what she
was asked is it going too far when you
start showing up at their homes or
harassing them in public and she would
not discourage the behavior in fact she
encouraged it she said well people are
very motivated they're very motivated is
that what she's gonna say when someone
actually takes a shot at one of these
politicians when there's an innocent
what I should say when there's another
assassination attempt was that what
she's gonna say then - well they're very
motivated
two days ago Hillary Clinton all but
explicitly called for more violence when
she said that you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for you cannot be civil
can't do it now let's let's keep
something in mind here a political party
that wants to destroy what you stand for
well that's that's that's the nature of
political disagreement of ideological
disagreement isn't it we stand for
different things you know you you want
to establish one kind of society and the
other side wants to destroy that vision
destroy that society and put a noose a
different kind of society place that's
that's the nature of disagreement so
what my point is what killer Clinton is
actually saying here is she's saying you
forget about destroy what you stand for
what you're saying is you can't be civil
with a political party that disagrees
with you it's impossible to civilly
disagree that's that's what you think
and this has been the Democrat approach
for years now this is not it's not a new
thing they intentionally fomented unrest
and spread misinformation that led to
riots in Ferguson
in Baltimore it seems like we've
forgotten about that we act like antifa
was the first iteration of these
Lebanese violent leftist mobs but no I
mean there were there were wide scale
riots happening in cities across the
country and again Democrats would not
condemn it wouldn't speak out against it
famously that the May the Democrat mayor
of Baltimore said well we're gonna give
them space to destroy we're gonna give
them space let them do it and they just
if I didn't and they continued spreading
the lies and the rhetoric hands up don't
shoot that kind of stuff that was
encouraging this kind of stuff now this
should go without saying but but I'll
say it anyway
as we're talking about temperament
Democrats apparently care about
temperament so much well a politician
who will not loudly and convincingly
condemn rioting harassment intimidation
tactics violence okay these are
politicians who do not have the
temperament for office and unfortunately
that describes almost every Democrat
politician at least on the national
level and probably most on the you know
more localized level as well
politicians like that they're just far
too
vengeful reckless to hold political
office and it's like it's one thing if
you have a Supreme Court justice who
gets pretty angry when you accuse him of
raping somebody okay that's one kind of
temperament but when you have a major
political party that's led by people who
will unapologetically incite violence
against their opponents that's a totally
different thing altogether now yesterday
Rand Paul came out and he warned is the
very strong words he warned that there
might be an assassination so he's
speaking explicitly about assassinations
using that word the a word that you
don't hear that very often coming from
politicians he said that he's worried
there
gonna be an assassination and he said
that those who are quote ratcheting up
the conversation they're gonna bear some
of the responsibility that's a strong
strong words from Rand Paul especially
coming from a guy who was who was if you
may remember attacked and badly beaten
just last year so he knows what he's
talking about and these warnings coming
from him we should listen to them but
Democrats are going way in the other
direction Eric Holder yesterday he he
told a crowd a cheering crowd he said
when they go low we kick them that's his
message he also called for Rage he said
we need to have Rage and this is the
most startling thing he openly
questioned the legitimacy of the Supreme
Court now keep something in mind here
when Eric Holder questions calls into
question the legitimacy of our governing
institutions and Maxine Waters tells her
supporters to follow Republicans around
and tell them they're not welcome
anywhere and Hillary Clinton says that
well we can't be civil with Republicans
because they're so evil and Hirono
justifies mob behavior by calling the
the mobbing hordes motivated and when
Cory Booker tells his base that they
should quote get up in the faces of
Republican Congressmen all of this stuff
when they do that we could only conclude
one of two things okay either number one
these Democrats are too stupid to know
what they're doing they really don't
know what they're doing because they're
stupid or number two they know exactly
what they're doing and I'll put it this
way I don't think they're stupid I don't
I think that these people are actually
relatively clever they know exactly what
they're doing that's the second option
and so the only real question I think is
whether Democrats are simply unconcerned
with the violence that they might cause
or if they actively want the violence
and there's a pretty
either way it's terrible there's still a
pretty big difference between those two
things are they actively trying to
incite violence or is it just that they
know that they may be inciting violence
but they don't care as long as they
achieve whatever their their ultimate
political aim I think there's plenty of
reasons to reason to suspect that this
is that this is what they actually want
politicians we should remember are very
calculated
especially Democrat politicians
especially Democrat politician like
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton never
says anything that hasn't been thought
about ahead of time she goes in and she
says something she knows what she's
saying and she's saying it for a reason
so when she says we can't be civil okay
that was not just something she said on
a whim off the top of her head in a
moment of passion she doesn't have
moments of passion this was something
that she thought about and this was a
plan that this is what were this is what
we're gonna go with so there's a reason
why there's a reason why these people
have chosen now in a moment in time when
tensions are so high when divisions are
so deep when anarchists are in the
streets shutting down traffic senators
families are receiving graphic death
threats which is what was happening
during the Kavanagh confirmation there's
a reason why they've chosen now in the
midst of all that to start using this
especially militant language somebody
like Eric Holder who was the Attorney
General of the United States not too
long ago he doesn't he he's not going to
get up there and announce that this is
the direct quote he said the legitimacy
of the Supreme Court can justifiably be
questioned he doesn't say that on a whim
okay that's not a moment of passion he
well knows what happens when people
start to believe that the government is
not legitimate okay he knows what
happens
so they're doing this on purpose now
there is another thing to consider here
it's it's kind of an interesting wrinkle
the interesting thing is that the side
the political side that seems to be
chumming the water for civil unrest
there also the side that opposes gun
ownership right there was an editor at
Think Progress recently who said on
Twitter that Republicans should be
confronted quote where they eat and
where they sleep again he knows what
he's saying confront somebody where they
sleep what else does that does that mean
besides go into their house so he's
saying that yet and this is right in
line with what these other more browner
Democrats have said like what Matt
Maxine water said it's all in the same
thing he's so he's saying that yet
Republicans are the ones with all the
guns so you confront I mean it's it's
probably not gonna work out well for you
if you try to go into a conservatives
house and confront them where he sleeps
the left seems to be itching for this
confrontation with people who have them
outgunned by like three to one that's
the statistics there are I think there's
about three times more Republicans who
own guns than there are than there are
Democrats so it's just it's a miracle
that that's one of these motorists are
innocent bystanders who have been
assaulted at a mt4 rallies it's it's a
miracle that one of them hasn't pulled a
firearm by now it's it's it's only a
matter of time it seems like we when you
start chasing people down in their cars
and begging on their cars and all this
kind of stuff trying to intimidate them
screaming in their face assaulting them
you start doing that I guess if you do
it in Portland you know your chances are
pretty good that they're gonna be
unarmed but you start doing that kind of
thing and you're really asking for
trouble
and if the left plans to really ratchet
up the violence which is what we're
seeing then the chances seem to be
greatly increased that they're gonna
find themselves on the wrong end of one
of those confrontations so that's that's
an interesting part of this and you have
to wonder is that part of the plan I
don't want to get to Conspirator you
know I don't wanna get into conspiracies
here but do Democrats want gun owners to
start losing their cool in the face of
provocation or have they not far thought
that far far ahead I'm not sure or do
they figure that it works out for them
either way because if you if you start
it you know if you if you if you if you
if things really get violent and you can
intimidate Republicans and conservatives
into backing down then you kind of get
your way but on the other hand if you
are able to incite more of a two-way
kind of violence if you're able to get
that going well then you have a case now
you're gonna use that as a case to
restrict the Second Amendment so so
maybe that's their thought I don't know
or maybe they just haven't thought that
far ahead but but either way the
strategy is diabolical and it's
dangerous and we are as I said headed to
a very bad place if they don't put an
end to this and I'll tell you the thing
here's what really concerns me okay I
think that where we're on a powder keg
as the saying goes and the powder in the
keg consists of a few things we have as
we've talked about the deep ideological
divisions and the contempt that's felt
by the two sides towards each other we
have the reckless at best rhetoric
coming from politicians or trying to
trying to wind up the crowd but then we
also have the kind of loss of a sense of
a shared humanity what I mean is we were
a very morally numb Society and we
struggle to see the humanity and the
personhood in our fellow human creatures
and that's not just because of political
divisions it's also
because we live you know living as we do
in a way where we're experiencing so
much of life and interacting so much
through screens through the internet I
think it really has a numbing effect and
I think people today often struggle to
see the sacredness of life they struggle
to see the humanity in their fellow
human so much so that I think people
will join a mob a lot of these mobs and
riots and chaos that we've seen I think
there are people who jump into that
because they they happen to hate whoever
or whatever they're rioting against but
I also think there are a lot of people
who jump into it just for fun because
it's something to do because it's all a
game to them it's all entertainment and
this is how they've learned to see life
and they just don't recognize they don't
see the seriousness of what they're
doing and if somebody gets hurt or
killed they don't care that much because
as I said they don't recognize the
humanity of the people who are getting
hurt or could get hurt
and I just worry about all these factors
we've already got all these factors
together kind of in a in one mix and now
you throw in what these Democrat
politicians are doing now and the things
that they're saying is that gonna be the
match that really lights it I guess
we'll see but I think these are
precarious times let's just say so pray
for our country
and I'll talk to you tomorrow Godspeed